I am a big fan of the walking dead as
I've said and I've gotten a chance to
interview most of the cast I would think
that when you watch that show it's a
workout for you guys just as actors
because there's no way to fake what
you're doing you are in the hot Sun
running most the time you're running
you're jumping over things you're
climbing you're fighting zombies is it
actually keep you in shape we don't even
get to wear our pedometers either your
pedometers yeah like our step counter oh
like your Fitbit a Fitbit yeah like I
feel like I feel like I'd beat my
average Lauren count if I had a Fitbit
on during the Walking Dead that's right
you know you wear one in regular life
yeah everyone all the time yeah I rarely
run out of time I remember I wore one
for a while and it clips onto your jeans
and then I put it through the wash like
seven different times yeah because you
forget to unclip it yeah just throw it
in the washing machine
and then it said that I had gone 10,000
miles yeah it was blinking and I knew
something's wrong yeah this isn't
Estella performance this is just that
the equipment is broken yeah right so so
you know that is interesting it would be
interesting if the zombies war because
they walk eternally if they were Fitbit
they would get into amazing zombie I
don't know if it measures if she doesn't
actually use those for the commercials
what the zombies should advertise that's
if they did know just during the
commercial breaks but the funny thing is
sorry
no go ahead no I was gonna say the funny
thing is that my friend and I have
different fitbit's and her says she does
most episode me and it always really
obsessed me because we're walking
together during the same distance and I
thought well maybe she has so much
longer shorter legs than me and that's
why it calculates for that but she
doesn't she has longer legs than me so
then I thought if you and I walk
together would you does it calculate our
mileage I have the longest legs of any
man in America I heard that you have a
custom-made bicycle because you like
this my legs are so long I have a
disproportionate body I have the legs of
like ass 9 foot tall man and then I have
the torso of a 4 year old girl
so right here my chest is right around
here yeah my penis is here underneath
when I'm in a urinal you don't even want
to know why the point is I'm a hideous
freak of nature so when I would had a
Fitbit it would say at the end of the
day I would walk like 50 miles and it
would say five steps yeah so it was
taking these long crazy war that's like
the John Cleese thing yes because if I
did it like if you did one step and I'd
have to do seven steps let's see one of
your steps to my left
yup got long legs oh yeah and I just
made them quick I just pulled up my
pants comically high yeah so you just
take one step what wait what no it's
just your legs are so that's been my
curse throughout my life is the long
luscious legs
you